yep okay thanks for waiting so much yeah
we do Stacy's cool that was part one of
my talk and now onto part two so I'm
gonna be talking about some new results
which are joint work with Shenton of
Chakraborty and and Roush Gillian who's
right here and so we have some new
algorithms for a quantum version of the
least squares problem also called linear
regression and so the first thing I'm
going to do in my talk is I want to
actually State our results which is
non-trivial to do and then if I have
time I would like to talk about some of
the techniques we use which is this
block encoding that Robins already
mentioned this is something that sort of
been developed in in several pass works
may be more or less explicitly and I
think it's becoming clear that this is a
nice framework for working with
algebraic linear algebraic problems so
let me start by first defining the
problem that we're going to talk about
so at least squares fitting or linear
regression is a problem that comes up
it's a very it's a very basic data
analysis problem or machine learning
problem if you like where we're given
some data points that are somewhat
linear so we kind of hypothesize that
this data is arising from some linear
function but they're noisy data points
so they're not fitting perfectly on a
line and we want to give a model a
linear model that describes this data so
that we can you know predict new data
points for example so more precisely we
are given the data points as input in a
matrix and a vector x and y where the
eyuth row of X and the I F entry of Y
encode the I of data points so we have
the the iya throw of X is giving us the
independent variable and then the I F
entry of Y is giving us the dependent
variable this is how we we receive the
data and how we actually get this matrix
and this vector is a very important
question which I'll talk about shortly
but for now just assume that we're
somehow given this data and we make an
assumption that
the data is well approximated by a
linear function so specifically we're
supposing that there is some linear
function f that describes the data but
then when we actually receive a data
point we we get Y sub I with some with
some random error added to it and so
that's why you know of course this would
be very easy if we just got some points
on a line but because of this noise the
problem becomes a bit more difficult the
realm of ordinary least-squares is to
find a linear function that that well
approximates the state and the following
sense so we we want to find a vector
beta which is going to describe the
linear function and we want to find a
beta that minimizes this expression here
so Y I is our actual measured value f of
X I and this is our hypothesized value f
of X I it's it's hypothesized to be the
output of this linear function and we
want to minimize the total squared error
over all M of our data points yes yeah
you can kind of just push the constant
term into like you know one of your
variables so we'll we'll suppose no
constant term and that can kind of be
taken care of by adding an extra
dimension okay so this is the problem of
ordinary least-squares and with some
manipulation we can see that the beta
that optimizes this will have this form
in particular it's just the pseudo
inverse of X applied to Y of course if
this if there were no error then we
would just be doing inverting a linear
function but here in particular there's
some error so this is this is the beta
that we actually need to find
okay so another problem we might
consider is a weighted least squares
problem where instead we're trying to
minimize this weighted sum of squared
errors and this is good for cases where
perhaps we we know that some of our
samples are better than others and so we
use some weights to sort of describe our
confidence in the samples and it's not
part of the it's not part of our job to
find these weights we assume that
they're given and so if we assume
they're sort of given as the diagonals
of a matrix W and we can see that you
know similar to the above expression
beta is the optimal beta is exactly this
where we've just sort of had to scale
things by W and it can also be expressed
in terms of a pseudo inverse and then
the final case that we consider is
generalized least squares and this is
for cases where you know you might know
that D your errors are correlated for a
certain so certain points the errors of
certain data points might be Co related
and so we assume that in addition to the
data points you're given some invertible
correlation matrix that sort of
describes correlations between the
errors and then in that case we want to
find a beta that minimizes this
expression and here this is the IJ entry
of the inverse of Omega rather than the
inverse of the IJ entry of Omega and you
know similar to the above we have a
closed form expression for this so we
want to find this beta this is the beta
that will minimize this expression given
in terms of the data matrix X and our
correlation matrix Omega is everything
that you're gonna say very specific to
and
I seen oh yeah everything here is a
specific tattoo so I mean I think in and
for this for this problem because it's
called least-squares so I think it is
normal to consider the squared error but
yeah I think everything that I'm saying
will not work for ya it could be
interesting to consider but I think it
would be much more difficult to sort of
generalize these these techniques but
okay so these are some different
varieties of this least squares problem
and we're not actually going to solve
any of these problems in my talk we're
actually going to consider quantum
versions of these problems so whereas
for the classical of problems we always
wanted to find this vector beta so we
wanted to find you know a list of
coefficients of linear function we're
gonna ask for something that's maybe
less good which is that we actually want
to output a quantum state beta whose
amplitudes are proportional to the
coefficients of the vector beta and of
course this is this is a less good thing
to be able to do but we'll be able to do
this with much better complexity and the
hope is that since least squares comes
up in so many different applications
maybe in some of them you know is it
could be that it's good enough in some
cases to get a quantum state beta
although I have to admit I don't know
such an application I'm not going to
talk about how this might actually be
useful I'll just talk about how we might
be able to solve some of these problems
which I'll call quantum ordinary
least-squares quantum weighted least
squares in quantum generalized least
squares so now I have sort of almost
finished defining the problem but I
still haven't told you how the input is
given and there are a number of
possibilities for this and they changed
the problem
you know sometimes considerably so let
me talk about how we might actually
access the input one model that has been
mentioned already in several talks is
the sparse access input model at least
that's what I will call it in my talk
and here so we want to somehow access a
matrix a we're going to assume that the
matrix is sparse so there's some
parameter s that we
and we know that all of the rows in a
and all the columns and they have at
most s nonzero entries and then we'll
have we'll be able to query a in three
different ways
so first we'll have some Oracle that
takes a row index I and a kay between
one and s and it tells us the index of
the case nonzero entry of the iya throw
and we'll have a similar Oracle for
columns where for any column J we can
ask for the elf the index of the elf
nonzero entry in the J s column and this
helps us find nonzero entries of the
matrix which can be useful if there are
only few of them this could save us
considerable work and then we also have
a third Oracle which for any I and J
allows us to query the IJ entry of the
matrix okay so this is the sparse access
input model you know this is an input
model so we don't have to talk about how
you would actually implement these
Oracles they're just given to you now I
want to talk about a different kind of
input model where we would we access
information that is stored in a certain
way in memory so we want our quantum
algorithm to be able to access some
classical information stored in memory
and one way for a quantum computer to
access of classical information in
memory would would be the the model of
quantum random access memory so okay so
suppose we have some array of memory
where we have you know like in will call
the contents of the ice memory cell X
sub I the classical random access memory
model allows you to sort of you know for
any eye you can produce X sub I from
this memory often this discount is just
sort of a constant time application
although in reality this should take
time proportional to log n because we
can sort of imagine that there's some
tree like structure hooked up to this
memory where if we want to query the I
if index the bits of I will tell us some
paths of length log n down this tree
that takes us to the ithe memory cell
from where we can access X sub I so you
know we we sort of can't really say that
the gate
city of this is log n because this this
tree like circuit is going to have n
gates but if you do a classical query
you're just going to go down a path of
length log and activating log n gates
okay and what we want is a quantum
version of this so we want to be able to
even though this is this memory is
holding some classical string we want to
be able to access it in superposition so
we want to be able to implement this map
unitarily so that we can query a
superposition of different indexes in
the memory now I'll just mention there's
some debate about you know whether this
is possible and what the cost of this
should be you know here if you're sort
of have a superposition of paths down
this tree then you can't really argue
that you're only activating log n of the
gates I don't really want to get too
much into this because I think I have
not so much time but we're going to
assume that we have quantum random
access memory that we can query in time
log N and if you really hate this
assumption well the depth of the circuit
is log n so you can suppose that I have
a parallel a quantum computer we're
going to assume quantum random access
memory that we can query in in time
login so given a quantum random access
memory we now we want a way of encoding
in this memory something like say a
vector that's useful for a quantum
computer so one really useful thing
would be if we can encode a vector
that's a description of a quantum state
and then efficiently generate that
quantum state so we want to define a
data structure that can encode an n
dimensional vector so that in in like
you know Palio log n we can generate a
state where the amplitudes are
proportional to the entries of that
vector there's also going to be some
poly log 1 over epsilon you know due to
truncating and implementing things
precisely but I'll kind of sweep all
these details under the rug ok so how we
might we do this so we're going to store
V in a tree in a tree like structure
where we will store the entries of V at
the leaves of the of a binary tree so
for example here's a four dimensional
vector stored at the leaves of this tree
and at every internal node we're gonna
store the l2 note of the two children so
for example here we'll have the l2 norm
of v-0 and v1 here we'll have the l2
norm of V 2 and B 3 and then at the root
of this tree will have the l2 norm of
these two values which is also the l2
norm of all of the leaves so every
internal node will have the l2 norm of
its two children which is also the l2
norm of all leaves below it and I'll
just show you for this example how we
can in log n operations create this
state so first we're going to you know
starting at the root we're gonna look at
these three values so the value at the
root and the value at it's two children
and that's going to tell us a rotation
that we should do so we're just going to
do this rotation to generate the state
and then second conditioned on the value
in in this register we're either gonna
look at this child or this child and do
the same kind of rotation using the node
and it's two children so for example if
we're in the zero branch of the super
position we're going to look at this of
the value at this node and it's two
children and we're gonna do this
rotation which depends on these three
values and similarly when they're in the
one branch of the super position from
from this node we're going to do this
rotation and you can see that just in in
sort of operations proportional to the
depth of the tree we've already
generated the State v so this allows us
to create this state given this data
structure in like log n operations okay
so what can we say about this data
structure if we want to generate such a
data structure of course if we're
inserting you know and and different
values into it it's going to take time
proportional to to end that's something
that we can't avoid but you know if you
imagine that you have some some stream
of values I VI not necessarily in any
particular order you can insert each of
them into this data structure in poly
log time and so you can sort of
initialize this data structure from a
stream of data in in time that's like an
poly log however once you already have
the data structure if you want to use it
to generate this vector that's just
going to take poly log time so we're
going to in our applications we're
we're going to ask that we be given data
in this night nice form which is a
little bit cheating but if you wanna if
you want to do some operation on a huge
data set you have to have collected it
at some point and you know if you had
some forethought and stored it at
collection time in this nice way then
you'll be able to use our algorithms I
mean if one can show that a classical
algorithm at the same data structure
can't solve the problem you know one of
the I mean I think that's all the
arguments a yeah I think it's I think
it's like a worthwhile model with the
information we have so far okay so but
we actually want to encode not just
vectors but matrices as well so we say
you want to encode an N by N and matrix
so here's one way that you could encode
it so I'm gonna call this the Frobenius
norm QR m encoding of a and you're going
to you know for every row of a you're
gonna encode in the data structure I
just described in this tree like data
structure every column of a that's a
these are all just vectors so you're
also going to encode every column of a
and this in this tree like data
structure and similarly you're going to
encode a vector of the row norms of a
and a vector of the column norms of a
and I'll call this the the Frobenius
norm Q Ram encoding of a it has some
useful properties so one we can sort of
initialize it from a stream of data in
just you know some time proportional to
the number of things the number of
nonzero entries in the matrix we can
also generate these sort of quantum
states corresponding to the the rows or
the columns in poly log complexity also
you know less clear why this would be
useful but we can also generate this
sort of vector of row norms or of column
norms in poly log complexity there's
other ways we can encode a and I'll
mention the other ones that are of
interest to us so for any for any P
between 0 & 1 I'm going to define mu sub
P of a to be this quantity so here we
have the largest l2p norm of any row of
a to the 2 piece power the largest L to
1 minus P norm of any column of a to
this to 1 minus P of power this is not
such an important expression I mean it's
important but like you shouldn't try to
memorize it or something
and then for for this value I'm gonna
I'm going to have a QM encoding called
the Mew P of a QM encoding it's gonna
also have some vectors related to a I'm
not going to say the details
the reason it's sort of named after this
quantity is because this is going to be
the normalization of some of the vectors
in the encoding okay and so I have these
different ways of encoding matrix a and
QM they can all sort of be initialized
in the same nice way and then what you
can do with them is going to be
different so your algorithms we're
working with them are going to be
different as well so now I've sort of at
least mentioned all of the the different
input models that I want to consider and
I can start stating the results so first
I'll mention some previous work so the
first
so this first algorithm for quantum
ordinary least-squares which is by
nathan and brown and lloyd from 2012 is
in the sparse access input model and as
this complexity here where s is the
sparsity epsilon to the desired accuracy
Kappa is the condition number of the the
data matrix and then M is the number of
input samples and this was improved in
2017 in the condition number of course
these these could also these explicit
ease could also be these are both based
on on linear system solving so probably
by updating the linear system solvers
that they use the complexities could
also be improved so you know these are
not necessarily meant to reflect the
state of the art but these are as stated
and ok then also recently Karen itis and
Prakash gave some algorithms for quantum
weighted least squares in the these
different Q Ram models so here mu should
be thought of as ranging over the
Frobenius norm or these new sub Peas
that I mentioned they're sort of a
family of different input models you
know you have to kind of decide when
you're storing the data which input
model you're like which way you're going
to store it and then given such an input
you you get a quantum algorithm for
weighted least squares and the
complexity is going to depend on the
input model so this mu would for example
could be the Frobenius norm of this
matrix the the weight matrix times
your data matrix X sorry just a very
naive question if I wanted to do
everything classically and get bit
classically what's the best or weighted
least squares or we're getting the
values of beta I mean I guess that you
would have to I mean the lower there's a
lower bound of n times M of the
dimensions of the matrix I mean I'm not
sure if if it's possible to meet that
lower bound but I think you can get
pretty close I don't know if you do this
and then you just use the your beta to
measure the coefficients of beta many
times I guess in some cases I mean you
also have this mu right so you could be
like mu could be it could be so mu for
example if you're in the the input model
where this is the Frobenius norm so that
would be sort of the one that I that I
showed most clearly then this would be
the Frobenius norm of a and that could
be like em like square root of n just
going even if you do I even if you do
yeah
okay so our contribution is our first
contribution is that we improve this
weighted least squares algorithm so we
improve from Kappa to the six to just
linear in Kappa in all also all of these
different mu QM models we also improve
the dependence on epsilon from one over
epsilon to poly log 1 over Epsilon and
our algorithm also works in the sparse
access input model so that with
essentially the same algorithm in the
sparse access input model we now get
complexity that depends on the sparsity
and these are for weighted least squares
and we also give the first algorithm for
quantum generalized least squares now
here remember the input is we have X and
we also have Omega in the input and so
this depends on the condition numbers of
X and Omega and then these mused upend
on your input models so for example if
we're in the Frobenius norm input model
this would be the Frobenius norm of X
and this would be the Frobenius norm of
Omega and you know this algorithm also
works in the sparse access input model
where now we have the dependence on the
sparsity of X and you know I could
imagine like that the destructor allows
me to sample from my so you could
imagine sub something and then solving
the problem and then that would allow me
to sample from the coefficient of 0 yeah
ok so that so it's true it's not it's
not completely clear that the the naive
lower bound still holds certainly
there's nothing known that you could do
with this data structure mmm it could be
because it hasn't been looked at I mean
yeah I mean I sort of think that like
okay I would be surprised if it works in
general but it might there might be good
heuristics or something that yeah yeah
that's oh that that's a good point I
guess we would want to like compare what
you can do classically with these data
structures that are kind of I mean for a
really fair comparison I think you would
you should even allow the data to be
generated in the same amount of time but
to make a good classical algorithm as
well but I don't know of anything that
then does better than n times M ok so
now that I that I've managed to state
our results I want to talk a little bit
about the techniques that we use and so
now I want to talk more about this block
encoding framework that Robin mentioned
and so I'm going to define now another
possible input model which is that you
know you the way your quantum algorithm
interacts with the input a you know you
want to solve some some problem where at
least part of the input is some matrix a
and the way you're going to interact
with this matrix is that you have some
unitary where a is the top left block a
is not necessarily unitary itself and
you know like I'll try to justify why
this is a good input model you might be
thinking how do we implement this
unitary but I mean this is just the
input model so we assume we're making
the assumption now that we have such a
unitary you might also notice that this
is not generally going to be possible
you know because this will this will
only be possible for a that has spectral
arm at most one so we could also allow a
to be scaled by by some constant alpha
and of course we'll also allow some
error so you you can just approximate
the matrix of this form and then more
precisely will say that you as an alpha
a epsilon block encoding of a if you
know we can approximate this matrix of
this form with alpha here using a
auxilary cubits so we have the space
that we need our matrix a to act on and
then we have little a auxilary cubits
and so more precisely if we kind of
isolate the top left block of you by
looking at the part
we're the silic you bits are set to zero
then we'll have something that if you
scale it by alpha gives a two with an
error Epsilon so notice that we're
actually epsilon over alpha
approximating so our unit area is
epsilon over alpha approximating a
matrix of this form
so this is what we call a block encoding
and now okay what's something obvious
that we could do with a block encoding
so one thing we could do is this this
you know this problem this very basic
thing where we just want to multiply a
state by a matrix by not necessarily
unitary matrix so we want to be able to
take some state B and and output some
you know a times B up to normalization
and in all of our applications we will
always be assuming that B is something
that you have some subroutine for
generating so we don't have to use the
oblivious amplitude amplification not in
this case okay and we can pretty easily
do that in this setting so if you have
some unitary of this form you can apply
it to be and all the unsolicited 0 and
so that's gonna be pretty close to just
taking you know some unitary with this
block in the top left corner multiplying
it with this vector in the top here and
so that's just going to give you a
applied to be up to this scaling in the
part of the state where the unset to 0
plus something that has the insulin not
set to 0 and so now using amplitude
amplification you can just amplify this
part of the state to get the desired
state and the ER the number of rounds
you'll need will be linear in alpha your
scaling factor okay so if you wanted to
do matrix multiplication by this matrix
a then this would give you a way of
doing it so this is just a really basic
thing that you could do with a block
encoding so now like I'm gonna talk
about how we implement a block encoding
because you know it's really nice to
have to say if we had a unitary of this
form it would be useful but why should
we ever assume we have a unitary of this
form okay so let's try to think about
how to implement this so suppose I have
two unitary x' you are and ul and I'm
going to call the first n columns of U R
so I went up to sy n so they're the
first n rows of you are dagger and you
know you might act on a on a space of
dimension much larger than n but I'm
only going to give names to its first n
columns and similarly I'm gonna call the
first n columns of ul by 1 up to Phi n
and then if I multiply you are dagger ul
I'm
get something that in the top-end by n
top-left block I'll have you know this
end by n matrix whose entries are given
by psy I Phi J nothing I've said is is
deep or interesting so far I'm just sort
of telling you how a matrix
multiplication works so this is a you
know so far they're very simple now I
want to define some particular size that
have to do with a so now I'm gonna let
I'm gonna let say I just be a
superposition whose amplitudes are the
values in the I throw so this is just a
state corresponding to the AIA throw of
a and I'm gonna define Phi J is just
going to be a superposition over the row
norms of a but J is just sort of going
to effect a label here but really it's
all sort of the same superposition and
then you can see that you know if I
define the vectors this way I do have
that psy I Phi J is just the IJ entry of
a up to the Frobenius norm
so what that means is that you are
dagger ul is a block encoding of a and
so to implement a block encoding of a it
would be sufficient to implement you are
and ul so you are is just any unitary
that Maps I between 1 and n 2 this this
row super position and ul is just any
unitary that map's J to this super
position and these are these are super
positions that I can generate if I have
my matrix a stored in the Frobenius norm
QM encoding and so this means that if I
have a in this Rubinius norm QM encoding
I can implement this block encoding of a
and without going into the details more
generally for any mu that's the
Frobenius norm are one of these new sub
peace of a then if a is in the museum
encoding model there there's some block
encoding with scaling mu that I can
implement with with poly log complexity
and we also have that if a is given in
the sparse access model there's some
there's a way to implement from that a
block encoding in complexity poly log
and over epsilon where now the scaling
is in terms of the sparsity
so if I develop an algorithm in the
block encoding framework that algorithm
will apply both to these different QM
models and also to the sparse access
model
so so this is one reason why you might
want to develop algorithms in this model
but another reason is that it's actually
is actually kind of nice to work with
this model so let me show you some of
the things that you could do if you have
your input in this model so one is that
if you have to block encoded matrices
it's easy to compose them so you can
kind of multiply them you know put the N
silla's in the right place and you'll
get a block encoding of the product so
the block encoding of a a block encoding
of B you can easily get the block
encoding of the product of a B you know
this is quite straightforward but
there's there's more complicated things
that we can do so for example lo and
Truong showed how to do hamiltonian
simulation in this model so starting
I'll put the I'll put this in sort of
the words of our work but starting in
from a block encoding of a hamiltonian h
you can also you can produce a block
encoding of e to the i th for for any T
and this implementing this V will
require calling this U as a subroutine
so specifically if the complexity of
implementing this U is some T sub u then
you'll be able to implement V in
complexity like this so the the the
algorithm for implementing V will call
you some number of times and you know
you can think of this alpha as being
sort of taking the place of the the norm
of H
okay and then you know seeing that you
can do Hamiltonian simulation in this
model a natural thing especially after
Robyn's talk that you might think is um
can we also do linear system solving and
so we can so given a block encoding of a
we can we can also implement a block
encoding of a inverse here the scaling
is in terms of the condition number of a
and you know if the complexity of
implementing this block encoding is tu
then you have this expression for the
complexity of implementing this block
encoding and so now we can see you know
we could use this to solve the quantum
linear system profit problem so in this
problem you're given some matrix a and
some quantum state B and you want to
output a inverse B so how would we do
that here well we could apply V which we
know how to implement in this complexity
to be with some ancillary in so a qubit
set to zero and we'll get this which we
can amplify to a inverse B but notice
that we'll have to amplify this we'll
have to run V like linear in K times and
so the complexity of doing this who will
be or sorry in kappa times the
complexity of doing this will be Kappa
times this expression which will in
particular be quadratic in Kappa and in
other models we know how to do this in a
way that is linear in Kappa and so in
this model we can also we can also do
quantum linear system solving in time
that's linear in Kappa but we have to
sort of leave the block encoding
framework to do that so we also show
that given a block encoding we can solve
the linear system problem in time that
is linear in Kappa and it's using the
same techniques as have been used before
which is the variable time amplitude
amplification
okay so now that I've shown you some of
the things you can do with block
encodings I will very quickly talk about
how you can solve the problems that I
spent so long defining in particular
generalized least squares and luckily
it's very simple to work in this
framework so I can do this very quickly
the problem again is that our input is
some vector Y we'll assume it's in Q RAM
and you know some some matrices X and
Omega
I'll assume I have block encodings of
them that might be because I'm in the
sparse access input model or it might be
because I'm in one of these QM input
models all of them lead to nice block
encoding inputs and I want to output a
state proportional to this and so since
Y is in QM I can easily generate this
state and so if I had a block encoding
of this whole matrix here I would be
done I could just apply the block
encoding to Y so I'm going to now build
up a block encoding of this so first I'm
gonna use my block encoding of Omega to
generate a block encoding of Omega
inverse and then I'm gonna use my block
encoding of Omega inverse and I also a
block encoding of X as part of the input
now I can generate a block encoding of X
transpose Omega inverse next I can use
my block encoding of X transpose Omega
inverse and X to get this block encoding
now I can use this block encoding to get
a block encoding of its inverse and now
I can combine these two block and
coatings that I built up to get a block
encoding of the entire expression which
I can then simply apply to Y and do
amplitude amplification on this whole
process so this is like a very simple
way that I can just sort of you know
using here I only had to use these two
techniques of being able to multiply
block encodings and invert block
encodings and I could just build up this
larger algorithm now in doing this I
could not get the benefit of the
variable time amplitude amplification
that gives me better dependence on the
condition number and so we can actually
this is sort of a really nice algorithm
but with a little bit more work you can
you can actually do better but it's it's
sort of less nice
a few things I didn't mention so I won't
I won't talk about the details of
variable time absolute amplification but
it's some way that for certain
algorithms you can speed up amplitude
amplification we also give a technique
that allows you to get the same speed up
for estimating the amplitude or
estimating the success probability of a
variable time algorithm I think this is
a useful technique so you can ask me or
undress more about it later and using
this we also get some algorithms for
estimating electrical network quantities
in the QM model in the various QM models
okay so I'll just mention some for the
readings so this is the results that
I've been talking about and you can also
read you know more about block encodings
and even some additional techniques in
this paper which is just went off on the
archive last week so thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
yeah so I guess um that's a good
question I I don't know the answer for
this to be useful I guess you like would
have to somehow make use of having a
quantum state that that encodes your
solution rather than actually getting
the solution and it isn't clear how
useful that would be so hopefully
hopefully there would be someplace where
where this would be useful but you know
I so I guess the answer is I don't know
and you sort of asked first about like
you know if this would be if I could
envision this being used soon and I
think maybe this is not necessarily
going to be good for really near-term
stuff I really thought about that I
think this is more of like a large scale
it's actually kind of appropriate lady
Kenna clapping for Penn State
yeah I mean maybe I guess it's possible
that you could use your output states to
to kind of do this some sort of
classification but this is really
speculative so maybe you can say more
standard or other standard quantum
algorithms like one of bolts been
training or various forms of quantum
neural networks would be a lot better
suited in order to classify say you know
what face the ground state of a mini
body system is in for example what this
is with you a better job of it's a case
where your yield at a ground state are a
state out by some process and what you'd
like to be able to do is you would like
to be able to do a reconstruction of
that state in terms of a linear
combination of other quantum states that
are yielded by other processes
so you can do forms of tomography with
this that would be might be challenging
to do with other methods but whether
that that's practically in and of itself
is still not clear but it doesn't able
something that it that's not regular
very late
there any more questions well this text
I see in a movie
[Applause]